so I went out the commercial break about
a week ago we step out during the
commercial breaks and meet folks that
are stopping by our lobby and having our
we have free cookies and homemade
cookies and free coffee and all kinds of
goodies that miss melissa makes in the
in our little cafe here and people come
and watch the show and eat the free
stuff and all that not come out signed
books and take pictures all that kind of
lady handed me this she found her I
guess it was her great-grandmother or
her grandmother's marriage certificate
and she made a copy of it for me from
Iowa and the date on it is 1926 and
along with the marriage license or
marriage certificate which is very
interesting just to read the marriage
certificate was a thing that the
apparently the pastor had stapled to it
how to put this is from 1926 how to
perpetuate the honeymoon
number one continue your courtship like
causes produce like effects it worked
when you're recording it'll work when
you're married that's very interesting
wording do not assume a right to neglect
your companion more after marriage than
you did before number three have no
secrets that you keep from your
companion a third party is always
disturbing number four avoid the
appearance of evil in matrimonial
matters it is often that the mere
appearance contains all the evil love as
soon as it rises above calculation and
becomes love is exacting it gives all in
demands all make the best of the
inevitable persist in looking at and
presenting the best side number six keep
a lively interest in
the business of the firm - that do not
pull together are weaker than either
alone very good start from where your
parents started rather than from where
they are now ding ding this is wise you
handed it to me hollow and showy
boarding often furnishes the to strong
temptation while the quietness of a
humble home would cement of the hearts
beyond risk love the wording this is so
good I here we go
avoid debt spend your own money then it
will not be necessary to blame anyone
for spending other people's great 19:26
how to perpetuate the honeymoon do not
to get do not both get angry at the same
time it takes to to quarrel do not allow
yourself to ever come to an open rupture
things unsaid need less repentance that
phrase right there's tweetable matter of
fact that could just put Twitter out of
business things unsaid need less
repentance study to understand your
companions disposition in order to
please and avoid friction study to
conform your tastes and habits to the
tastes and habits of your companion if
two walk together
they must agree and here you go
gauge your expenses by your revenues
love must eat the sheriff the sheriff
often levies on Cupid long before he
takes away the old furniture I love that
stuff getting no but 1926 how to
perpetuate the honeymoon